we're about to see day two of historic
public hearings in the house impeachment
inquiry the former US ambassador to
Ukraine Murray Ivanovich a career
diplomat testifies this morning two
months after President Trump removed her
he told Ukraine's president in a
controversial phone call that she was
quote bad news and said she was quote
going to go through some things and
quote Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
for so Nancy good morning how is this
morning's hearing supposed to unfold
well Toni Democrats see it like this
day one of these public hearings on
Wednesday sort of laid out this entire
story from end to end now we hear from
the women who they see as chapter 1 the
first real casualty of this scheme that
Democrats are now describing as bribery
gee let's get some help from Ukraine in
order to beat sleepy Joe Biden now I
don't think so
at a rally in Louisiana last night
President Trump mocked the case against
him we did nothing wrong and they're
doing nothing but at least nine
witnesses have testified in public or
private that President Trump expected
Ukraine to investigate his political
rival today one of those witnesses
Murray Ivanovich will describe how she
was told this spring to watch her back
because the president's personal lawyer
Rudy Giuliani and his business
associates had mounted a concerted
campaign against her we were blocked by
the Ambassador who eventually got fired
she'll explain today how she felt
threatened by language the president has
used to describe her she was dedicated
as is every US government official in
Ukraine Jovanovic was sent home in May
which cleared the way for the so called
three amigos officials with a direct
line to President Trump to unofficially
take over Ukraine policy just the for
mr. Trump froze hundreds of millions in
aid to Ukraine they had begun to hear
from basser Sandlin that the security
systems was not going to come until the
investigations were pursued on Thursday
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi described the
president's actions with a simple
but significant word bribery that word
appears in the Constitution as grounds
for impeachment that's a very serious
charge what makes this a case of bribery
the bribe is too gradual withhold
military assistance in return for a
public statement of a of a fake
investigation Republicans are going to
argue today that Jovanovic isn't a true
witness to what Democrats are calling
bribery because she was recalled before
military aid was held up this summer
tomorrow congressional investigators
will interview mark sandy behind closed
doors he's the first official to speak
from the Office of Management and Budget
which would have handled that free as he
reportedly Tony had concerns that he
voiced about it this summer all right
Nancy